bonjour clovis vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial à kiev pauline godard parlé au
début de ce journal de ces images
satellites montrant un long convoi
militaire russe qui se dirigerait vers
kiev est ce que de là où vous êtes vous
en avez entendu parler est ce qu'on sent
la pression qui augmente sur la capitale
ukrainienne
absolument tout le monde en parle de ce
convoi qui
s'étend sur 60 km avec des de
l'artillerie des chars russes mais aussi
des camions de logistique qui ce qui
laisse penser que ces russes veulent
aussi à pouvoir se ravitailler donc
peut-être rester un petit peu de temps
aux abords de la capitale ukrainienne
alors beaucoup de gens parlent d'une
stratégie d'encerclement mais au vu de
la taille de la ville il semblerait
compliqué pour les russes de d'encercler
totalement à la ville mais certainement
ils vont chercher à se déployer autant
que possible bloquer les axes
stratégiques qui sortent de la capitale
pour ensuite viser tirer sur la capitale
sur des immeubles il faut dire que ce
matin il y a eu une attaque au missile
dans la ville de kharkiv qui aurait visé
le bureau à des autorités régionales
celle du gouverneur hier c'était avec
des missiles grad qui font forcément à
des dégâts auprès des civils donc s'ils
utilisent ce même type de missile sur
kiev ça pourrait être très très
compliqué et pour finir ici il y a eu
des tirs encore dans le centre-ville
hier donc une ambiance particulièrement
tendue
clovis vous avez pu sortir également
hier sept dernières 24 heures vous avez
rencontré des habitants de kiev que vous
ont-ils confié
et bien après un long long couvre-feu
qui a duré tout le week end qui s'est
terminée lundi 8h et bien les ukrainiens
étaient tout simplement heureux de
sortir il faisait beau hier pas comme ce
matin avec cette neige qui pour la
première fois tombe sur kiev depuis le
début de cette invasion russe
hier il y avait beaucoup plus de monde
dans les rues je vous dis beaucoup plus
n'était pas énormément non plus hein les
gens sortent uniquement pour faire des
achats de première nécessité tous les
restaurants toutes les boutiques presque
tout est fermé il ya seulement à
quelques
supérette on va dire quelques pieds de
boutiques où les gens peuvent se
ravitailler ou les gens rentrent
rapidement et sortent rapidement et puis
à des pharmacies vous l'avez vu dans
notre reportage des pharmacies elles
sont pas toutes ouvertes en plus des
pharmacies où les gens font la queue
pour essayer de se ravitailler en
médicaments on a par exemple rencontré
une dame dont le mari avait une crise
cardiaque une autre dame qui cherchait
des médicaments pour sa grand-mère pour
les personnes âgées une situation
compliquée pour eux et là c'est
justement la journée le temps de vite
aller chercher des provisions avant que
le soir et bien il y est c'est de
nouveau ces détonations encore plus
fréquentes et que les gens aillent se
réfugier dans des abris anti beaumont
était aussi à la gare je peux vous dire
que c'est peut-être l'endroit le plus
animé de kiev énormément de gens qui se
presse à la gare qui essaient qui se
poussent qui essayent de rentrer dans
des trains il ya très peu de trains pour
quitter la capitale il y en a un ou deux
par jour ça dépend aucune visibilité et
donc les gens se pressent ce pouce ce
sont les femmes et les enfants d'abord
qui peuvent remonter les hommes eux les
ukrainiens sont appelés à rester ici
pour combattre les russes prendre les
armes et défendre la capitale